welcome to installation number 20 in our
series worlds of speculative fiction
small-group tonight all of us old
regulars and we're going to talk about
William Gibson so I don't do any
introductions we can just jump right in
and have to explain how we do things
this is excellent
I do we have the the literary and
biographical timeline I thought we could
talk about that I have a number of
philosophical themes and I'm sure you
guys don't have some other themes that
you bring up as well and then I found a
number of interesting passages from
mostly interviews but but also from a
blog post that he did at one time so you
know Gibson with him we're entering into
just like we did last time with
Lovecraft going into horror we were
entering into a different genre within
speculative fiction that a cyberpunk
although you know if we wanted to call
it sci-fi I guess what if we could call
it that as well but it really was its
own thing for for a while and now it's
there's there's all these others like
sort of split off genres like dieselpunk
and that pumpkin and I think one of the
things that's the most remarkable that I
wanted to start out with and you see
this in some of these passages as Gibson
himself was not a techy guy at the time
that he wrote cyberpunk I really hate
that cyberpunk it time he wrote
Neuromancer and these earlier stories
like burning calm and Johnny Manama he
was typing on a typewriter
not even an electric typewriter and he
didn't have access to you know the
Internet until fairly late he willingly
concedes that that you know when it
comes to the contemporary and
something's totally wrong he didn't
predict certain technologies he's
totally upfront about that he doesn't
get an email address until 1996 for a
guy who was writing about you know the
neck and all that and he tells us well
how did people are how did you actually
know about what was going I said well
you know these other people were talking
about these things and I could have you
know overhear the conversations because
the other people that I was was hanging
out with it's fascinating and he's able
to like become the author known for this
stuff it's sort it would be sort of like
he was really into music and we'll talk
about about that in a minute
it'd be sort of like if somebody was
going to talk about the history of heavy
metal and they'd only listen to
classical music their entire life but
they'd heard distant conversations and
imagined what heavy metal does to their
lead piece so he's a really fascinating
character let's let's actually start
with one of these things so this is this
is from the heavy metal interview in
heavy metal magazine which was you know
part of the zeitgeist at the time and
they're asking him about his influences
and he says well a credit Starship
Troopers for saving me from Vietnam
because my reaction at age 14 was this
sucks
I read Naked Lunch pretty early around
16 I got bored with mainstream sci-fi
pretty fast and trusting for someone
who's going to be a sci-fi writer all
the writers i loved-ed say 15 fritz
leiber is the one who held up the best
and the more I learned of his life the
more respect the more I respect him for
what he's done
and get a lot more in the way of direct
inspiration from rock music he devoted a
lot of attention to punk bands and
expanding his record collection he says
I don't I don't read much sci-fi I
haven't read much sci-fi at month on
over 20 years there's so much other
great stuff to read now I read to gather
material and moment
from my own work and I just don't get
that from sci-fi philip k dick
oddly has had almost no influence on my
work now why would that come up I think
in part because you know dick was hot at
the time and I think a lot of people saw
connections between Gibson and dick he
says a strange fact in what I can't
explain except the combination of acid
and gravity's rainbow had something to
do with it
I dug the whole Punk thing from the
start or from when I was first aware of
it
1977 I felt kind of embarrassed because
I remember those dorky thirty year olds
who come sleazing around the scene in
1968 because he was part of the both the
hippie and music drug scene in the
sixties but the iconography of it was
just sheer beauty to me like like janae
and Burroughs rolled into one
[ __ ] shot semiotic spit ball nice little
alliteration there at the end and what
you can see in that is he's really not
he's kind of an outsider he's not
somebody who decided that he was going
to break into the field there there is I
guess you could say some you know
references and homage back to other
thinkers or writers but very often
they're not scifi writers right The Beat
poets for example if we look at his his
timeline you know his biography will
come back to this this stuff but there's
a lot of interesting stuff in there he's
born in the south you know in 1948 so
he's essentially a boomer right at the
you know early end of that he gets moved
around a bit you know because it was his
dad's work but his dad dies pretty young
and he dies in a way that's sort of
prosaic choking to death in a restaurant
you know on a business trip and Gibson
really hated where he was living he did
not flourish in the south he writes
being kind of a cocky kid the area the
areas that he lived in were obsessed
with basketball
I suppose you know so we're like living
in Indiana in certain respects where
people really take that seriously or or
other parts of the south where they take
football super sir any sports because
yeah
sporting you know we're gonna support
some sports and and so he was kind of a
loner you know so eventually his mother
thinks she's gonna punish him by sending
him off to boarding school and he's like
sounds great to me
sent me off then he goes to Tucson which
you know was probably not really booming
at the time but but certainly was it was
more than what they had going on down
there eventually his mother is gonna die
when he's about 18 he's not gonna finish
school and then he starts traveling he
goes to California goes to Europe goes
through a period of some depression and
sort of trying to find himself and then
you know the Vietnam War is heating up
he first he goes to the draft board and
he tells them that he's taken every drug
they can possibly think of to tradition
4s death and then he decides to go to
Toronto like a lot of other Americans to
try to avoid the draft he never does get
drafted and he says that technically he
wasn't avoiding the draft because he
didn't he didn't have to go and fairly
quickly he falls into a job managing a
head shop Toronto was kind of but in
part because of the influx of all its
American hippies right
it was starting to boom with like
American music and the drug scene and so
you get really involved in that and he
took a lot of drugs said he pretty much
tried everything that was available he
also admits that he was less he was less
about you know taking a stand against
the war and more interested in chasing
hippie women
and having a good time which i think is
kind of refreshing he's not an idiot
look at all you know and then he meets
this Debra Jean Thompson and he travels
to Europe with her he said that he
preferred to to find places where the
currency went very far and where they
were you know sort of coming out of
fascism so that he could observe that
sort of stuff going on here he had
already started in some theories about
science fiction and fascism - that are
it's always reminiscent of Michael
Moorcock and in his notion about a lot
of science fiction was really quite
regressive in many ways and eventually
he marries Debra and moves to Vancouver
he writes while she's teaching and they
have a child and then another kind of
funny thing happens he realizes that he
can make more money getting financial
aid as a student and then he would
working and whether he had enough to put
in a lot of work to do so so he enrolls
at Burton University of British Columbia
in order to get financial aid and he
starts doing an English degree he says
wow this is really good for me because
it exposed me to a lot of other
literature he took a class on on sci-fi
and then you know he becomes he becomes
interested in sci-fi again and then
starts starts writing stuff and then it
becomes aware of punk and he gets really
into the music scene and he starts
spending a lot of time just expanding
his record collection I mean we're
around enough to remember back when
people did have record collections and
you're younger than that but CDs um
those right and it was a big thing too
you know you got to hear this album and
then you've taken out very gingerly you
know what a scratch yeah oh we do we do
- we actually have to get we have to
Solomon because we know we're never
going to play them turntables are back
oh I know yeah
yeah total digression we thought about
digitizing them because you can get you
know a car yeah the digitizer huh yeah
but it's it's finding the time to
actually do that I don't know that we
actually listen to much of that stuff
again and probably a good portion of
them are scratched up you know so I
don't I think you can get a lot of it
online now
now what ends up happening is he works a
couple different jobs for about three
years and it doesn't write much and then
it meets this punk musician author John
Shirley at a sci-fi convention and
Shirley finds out that that Gibson has
already written a few stories and he's
like show me the stories and then he
sees that he's like these are good you
need to publish these Ann Gibson hadn't
really tried to do that prior to that
and so he starts writing again and he
takes this very first thing that's
published as fragments of a hologram
rose which he had written as a graduate
student or as an undergraduate student
in his sci-fi class and then he
publishes Johnny manam which gets turned
into a movie later on with remember
Keanu Reeves and then he also meets
these two other guys Bruce Sterling and
Louis shiner through through Shirley and
he starts selling stories to Omni and to
universe 11 Omni was kind of a big thing
in the eighties as far as sci-fi
magazines went it was where like you
know a lot of the new cool stuff was
coming out they always had really you
know for the eighties cool covers and so
you know that was it was kind of a big
thing now long after that maybe - he
actually appeared appears on a panel at
armadillo calm down in Texas called the
I am behind the mirror shades look at
Punk sci-fi and he gets paired up with
all these guys and they're the ones who
essentially come up
the turn and the beginning of the
movement of cyberpunk so Terry Carr who
he also gets introduced to is somebody
who's you know sort of acquisitions out
of here I think Commission's Neuromancer
for Ace science-fiction and now this is
a bigger deal right because he hasn't
written a novel before that and he's
written the short stories and the short
stories of done okay and he's brutally
honest does a great passage or he's
talking about Neuromancer and one of the
things he says is Neuromancer 'he's
fueled by my terrible fear of losing the
reader's attention once it hit me that I
had to come up with something and to
have a hook on every page I looked at
the stories I've written up to that
point and try to figure out what had
worked for me before I had Molly the
character with the razor fingers in
Johnny and my mom like genomic I had an
environment and burning chrome where we
you know I already sort of laid out some
of the key features of his world so I
decided I'd try to put these things
together but during all altering the
writing of the book and the conviction I
was going to be permanently shamed when
it appeared and I got even worse when
later came out in Haiti too because he
was like oh everyone's gonna think that
I'm copying Blade Runner because of this
sort of neo-noir aspect so he said even
when I finished that no one perspective
on what I've done I still don't for that
matter I always feel like what this is a
beautiful metaphor I feel like one of
the guys inside those incredible dragons
you see sneaking through the crowds in
Chinatown sure the dragon is very
brightly colored but from the insight
you know the whole thing is pretty
flimsy just a bunch of old newspapers
and paper mache and balsa struts so he's
got kind of impostor syndrome right he
said I knew I was so inexperienced I
would need a traditional plot armature
that had proven its potential for
narrative traction I had these different
things I wanted to use but since I
didn't have a preset notion of where I
was going the plot had to be something
I already felt comfortable with the
first two-thirds was written a dozen
times a lot of stylists have changed
this changes once a in the feel of the
world but also a lot of monkeying around
to make the plot so vaguely plausible
he's saying this yeah an 86 you know
after he's become very successful right
I had to cover up some of the shabbier
coincidences Chris yeah well also I
never had a very clear idea of what was
going to happen in the end except that
the gangsters and scoring so this is
almost kameena right and you know it
reminds me last year we did Eve and
Voight an avian voice you know great
classic science fiction writer had the
world of nulli a lot of people
complained about that and said the the
storyline has not really coherent and
it's incoherent in the same way that
like Joseph Heller's Canty to is not
actually coherent if you map out all the
things it works right but it's it's kind
of a mess to try to map out what's going
on - with Gilbert Josiah and all that in
the world of Nellie he's saying
something similar about his own work and
he's doing in effect what that boy had
coined as I'm trying to remember the
name and it's not a patch-up the idea is
you've got some some stuff already yeah
and you've got some material right and
then you just can expand it a bit there
is a technical name for it that pasted
up yeah and so I think that's what he
what he's saying he was doing with with
Neuromancer so it's really quite amazing
that it turned out to be as good as it
did you know there was been some some
you know talent and some things for
venting there in his so Neuromancer
comes out and now notice nerve
answer it wins a sort of a trifecta of
awards Hugo nebula and philip k dick
award like the year and right after it's
it's come out people are responding to
it it didn't get much press and he
points out later on the new york times
didn't take any notice of it for ten
years
and then notice what happens after that
you know count zero comes out two years
later
Mona Lisa overdrive comes out and only
then does he start using a word
processor all this time has been typing
and he tells us that he doesn't actually
know that much about computers we'll
look at a bit of that and then you know
he continues on and he's not a very
prolific writer I mean he just rated a
lot of interesting essays here and there
but he's not somebody who's like driven
to churn stuff out you know either for
commercial purposes like philip k dick
you know really had to keep the keep the
stop coming to like stay afloat
financially or some people I think are
much more prolific just because there's
so much going there's there's other
authors one of the things that I always
thought was very funny about Norman
Mailer somebody called them in a
literary imperialist and said that you
know any genre you could come up with
Norman Mailer would try to stake a flag
there and so it was constantly you know
writing that it was like this kind of
ego driven thing you get the idea that
would Gibson that really it wasn't the
case as a matter of fact he's writing
this like I don't know why people think
this stuff is that good and then later
he actually leaves the cyberpunk genre
he starts writing more realistic novels
trying to I suppose for like again he
says he there's no influence from philip
k dick but there's some parallels there
dick had is you know realistic novels
that he
which are quite good and are different
from the sci-fi things and you know I
think part of the things Gibson is able
to get a lot more traction than he does
he also contributes artworks and
installations of different things here
there he he doesn't do an awful lot with
you know adopting new technology he
actually says I'm not an early adopter I
like to wait until things are completely
settled and then I get into them like he
starts writing a blog notice when does
he start 2003 you know and he stops he
starts writing and he's like this is
kind of distracting me from getting my
book project done Eddie
cuts it off he's still you know kicking
and he wrote a book recently the first
rail which I haven't read he also
recently got some honorary doctorates
they must have given some commencement
speeches or something like that so
that's usually when they do that from
Simon Fraser University and Coastal
Carolina University I think it's kind of
cool except I've been Coastal Carolina
which is a small you know State
University I think it's cool that they
brought him in to talk about that so
before we go into some of the
philosophical themes there there was a
couple other things that I wanted to hit
on one at wou the other the other one is
business on the second page from the
cyberpunk interview project interview as
well this is where he talks a bit more
about his approach to technology and he
says I'm looking for images that supply
a certain atmosphere right now science
and technology seem to be very useful
sources but I'm more interested in the
language of computers than I am of the
technicalities on the most basic level
computers in my books are simply a
metaphor for a human memory I'm
interested in the hows and whys in
memory the ways it defines who and what
we are in how easily memory isn't
subject to revision when I was writing
Neuromancer it was
wonderful to be able to tie a lot of
these into the computer metaphor when I
arrived at the cyberspace concept while
I was writing Vernon Chrome I could see
right away it was resident in a lot of
ways by the time I was writing
Neuromancer I recognized that cyberspace
allowed for a lot of moves because
characters can be socked into apparent
realities which means you can place them
in any sort of setting or against any
kind of backdrop in some ways I tried to
downplay that because if I overdid it
I'd have an open-ended plot premise that
could be dangerous if you don't have to
justify what's happening in terms of the
logic of character and plot it count
zero the second main main novel I wanted
to slow things down a bit and learn how
to do characterization so he's saying I
didn't quite understand characterization
I was trying to learn it on the fly
right I was aware that Neuromancer was
gonna seem like a rollercoaster ride in
most readers you've got lots of
excitement but maybe not much
understanding of where you've been or
how you were heading there in the first
place I enjoyed being able to present
someone like Varrick in count zero but
apparently there's in any number of
realities he's got the city Barcelona if
he wants it even though he's just pile
of cells in a file somewhere my feelings
about technology are totally ambivalent
which seems to me the only way to relate
to what's happening today when I write
about technology I wrote about how it
has already affected my lives I don't
extrapolate in the way I was telling a
sci-fi writer should so he's got a very
different project he's you know we look
at him it's like oh he's a pioneer and
he it's interesting because an interview
after interview I didn't really put this
in there
people like talk about him as the man
who predicted the future and and all
that means like I didn't predict it at
all I just happened to get lucky you
know I made something up that resembles
you know some of what we do there's a
lot of things I didn't predict but you
forget about that because
affirmation bias and he's really quite
quite humble about that rather than you
know thinking that he was he was a
prophet and that's actually where you
know I don't know if either of you read
future shock so this guy this is a very
big book and you can see it in user
bookstores still everywhere usually in
paperback form future shocked by Allan
Topher it was came out it was yeah the
basic premise is that because of
Technology you know he was one of the
first people saying look things are
really speeding up to where in the past
we could sort of keep track of the
difference between the then and the now
and now it's getting too too quick so
we're already sort of like we're already
living in the future and don't realize
it and it's not like you know the
Jetsons future or something like that
it's something that is baffling us and
it's causing us anxiety and how are we
going to learn to live with it and so he
says this isn't a book Expo of luncheon
talk he says Toller warned us about
future shock but is this that we're
living in future fatigue for the past
decade or so the only critics of science
fiction I pay any attention to and slyly
declaring the future is over I wouldn't
blame anyone for assuming this is akin
to the declaration that history was over
and just as silly but they're really
they're talking about the capital F
future which in my lifetime has been a
cult if not a religion people my age are
products of the culture of the capital
of future the younger you are the less
you are a product of that if you're 15
or so today so this is back in 2010 I
suspect that you would have in a sort of
endless digital now city of a temper
ality enabled by our increasingly
efficient communal prosthetic memory I
also suspect you don't know it because
as anthropologists tell us one cannot
know one's own culture the future
capital F whether it be crystalline City
on the hill or radioactive post-nuclear
that we think is go on ahead of us
there's
merely more stuff things going on as
usual but continual change so that you
know for example you know the this
iPhone right I have an iPhone 5 that's
you know woefully out of date because
now we're up to iPhone 7 iPhone just
came out with yeah well actually ever
that's supposed to be whether they jump
to past eight nine because straight to
ten I guess you know but they you know
everything on this is continually being
updated and in the past we would have
looked at that is that's ridiculous why
not like build it right to begin with
and we're now on a new sort of design
paradigm where you just kind of throw
crap together and it's it's slightly
better than one you had before and we'll
kind of figure it out on the way we've
got massive security you know
liabilities built into these things that
you know even the coders don't know how
where although the problems with the
cold lie and somehow things just keep on
going and there's minor catastrophes
here in the air and and and yet things
managed to keep on doing that's that's
what he was talking about there and he
says don't mistake me for one of those
after the deluge people I've always
found those moments appalling and most
particularly when uttered by aging
futurists who of all people should know
better this newfound state of no future
is in my opinion a very good thing it's
Canada demonstrates a kind of maturity
and understanding that every future is
someone's past every present someone
else's future on arriving in the capital
F future we discover it invariably to be
the lower case now so that's a very
interesting way to look at time and
history and technological transformation
you know I think there and this is one
of the themes I'm going to talk about
there's a lot of people who get really
really worked up about you know the
future is gonna be so amazing
you know when we have our jet cars and
you know or we can transport from place
to place all of us have you know these
beautiful clean living spaces and
computers can just you know teach us
everything we need to know and and you
know if you think about like the
predictions that were made about like
what life is going to be like now
looking back at old movies and things
we're nowhere near that I mean we've got
amazing things that none of them really
thought about like you know the iPhone
and the raw power that it's got and how
it connects us with everybody now we're
close to the Internet of Things
right which which could be a good thing
or it could be a bad thing is you know
Philip dick has an Internet of Things
where they all charge your money to like
you know your door won't let you out
unless you give it a nickel you know
there was a great article that came out
recently about you know they somebody
summed it up does the Internet of
fascist things where they're gonna be
gathering information on you all the
time and networking and and maybe we
don't want Google to have all that power
but we you know we're happening that
time and we don't have any of the the
stuff that was supposed to be going on
you know our jobs are just pushing a
button like in the Jetsons or you know
we're not I mean we have people who do
live on like pills and things but we're
not doing that sort of thing we're
living in life that's very similar in
many respects to how it's been doing it
for a long time we just changed things
here and there so let's talk about then
what we'll get back to that death theme
a bit later let's talk about the setting
and the world that he's creating it's
partly a virtual world right he coins
the cyberspace idea turns out to be very
different than what we now know to be
cyberspace but it's a great imagination
as part and then there's the world that
everybody else is living in the real
world and that's kind of a for the most
part camera rundown the crappy world
although we've managed to explore space
you know we've got we've got topside you
know where people can live in you know
in space and orbitals and you know some
areas have become very toxic the sprawl
is this thing that you know in our time
we have the the Boston to Washington
corridor where it's just City all the
way down from Boston through New York in
New Jersey and I guess probably
Connecticut too right yeah all the way
down into Washington DC in this it
extends all the way to Atlanta so that's
built out further big parts of New
Jersey are toxic waste lands where you
know you gotta like check your food to
make and you can't drink the water
unless it's filtered you know various
areas in the world are under the control
of governments and other other areas are
much less under the control of
governments and more under the control
companies so you know it's it's talked
about its kind of a neo-noir universe
it's clearly a stratified society where
most people don't have a lot of
resources and have very little power not
a lot of prospects for moving up plenty
of moving down but there's there's
certain compensations right so they can
enjoy since 10:00
you know they can they can patch into
other people's lives instead of watching
TV they can just experience what the
actress or actor does so you can
and you that all day wine there's all
sorts of you know interesting drugs that
people can take and he claims different
names for them Gibson you know do a lot
about drugs so a lot to work with what
else I mean there's all the other kinds
of things that people like to do ranging
from you know fighting to stealing
things to just people watching going to
department stores all that's there and
it's a world where there doesn't seem to
be any sort of like overarching project
that makes sense of it all like you know
for why we have the Cold War right and
we can make sense of our lives in terms
of the Cold War and then now we have for
at least for some people the war on
terror or you know sometimes the culture
wars provide people with meaning there's
other you know projects that people can
buy into you get the idea there's
nothing like that in Gibson's world
there's a lot of local projects there's
a lot of sort of high-powered eight you
know not the agencies but but but
organizations or sometimes even people
who have a particular thing that they
want to achieve governments do exist but
the government's don't seem to have to
all that much control over things
anymore so there's nothing to sort of
give you could say absolutely meaningful
to this and then you know you've got the
whole virtual world and some of his
characters are these cowboys who you
know log in and
try to steal things from banks and you
know there's all this discussion of ice
you know these countermeasures you know
that are generated by artificial
intelligences and you got to figure out
how to break through them and so it
provides kind of an interesting backdrop
one of the things that Gibson is really
successful with it is never telling you
that much about the world it does it
through
he doesn't like give you any credit well
here's how this developed Edie yes a
character just descriptive narrative
yeah it's mostly through dialogue I
think which is you know smart you get us
hooked into it and you only have to give
enough to make sense of the situation
right and and somehow we identify with
that I mean what did you guys when you
were reading this stuff did you think
that you needed more in order for the
story that makes sense or too much
description when because I actually had
that about certain times the climax is
for its to be seen through Molly's eyes
everything is intensely visual except
deal yeah but he has there's actually so
much visual detail that I had no clue
what to focus on and kind of zoned out
which might also be possible because he
never idea what he was building towards
there yeah but if that was it's famous
for its imagery like it opens with the
static comparison for the sky and
everything yeah I found that there were
places where he would do like a list and
it was visual stuff anything like here's
what I you know what was being seen and
it would be like a jumble of stuff and
you you were like you know I don't know
what the hell this is supposed to be but
I don't care about this list make
something happen
you know it almost seemed I think maybe
that's part of you know maybe maybe that
makes it a little dated because I think
that was kind of a technique that was
used by quite a few authors and like the
60s 70s 80s more conquerors kind of dad
for that sometimes - I don't really what
did you find
it's been a long time since I read Oh
long time but it occurs to me as you're
talking about if he's doing it through
the eyes of the character yeah and he's
making Liss maybe it conveys something
about the state of the mind of the
person who's listening mm-hmm yeah I
mean it could be nothing
they just can't focus on they're not
able to focus or they're jumping from
here to there yeah what they're folk it
says something about what they're
focusing on yeah I mean that's another
thing - so he he typically likes to work
by having a couple different narrative
lines going with characters and then you
know they they get brought together more
or less in some way by the end right but
they're each their own coherent
narrative they could be split apart and
no single one of them really dominates
except maybe I guess you could say cases
narrative in Neuromancer does the
Knollys of the people she's pretty
important too
it's an interesting feature he does a
really good job in being pretty
minimalist but but I'm still getting a
world there you know and their leaves a
lot of open possibility I mean one of
the cool things about this is it spun
off like a whole secondary literature
you know cyberpunk stuff and then like a
role-playing game you know I don't know
I never actually played that we created
characters for it but then that nobody
ever really got around to doing it that
was the case of lots of role-playing
games
and you know it's it's fun you know
movies too
so in many in some respects it was very
successful in there's almost like a
virus you know well this time I wasn't
reading a lot of science fiction at this
time because I was in my career yeah and
I wasn't another time to realize I know
I was like this time I didn't read it
until about 7 years ago and I read it
because aunt and II have it on a
bookshelf and I was like you know I
heard a lot of people talk about how
great this book is maybe I should read
it so I picked it up and I was like this
is pretty good stuff you know but I
didn't read the other ones until I you
know for getting ready for this
enjoy
I think they they stand up so let's talk
about some of these these key you know
philosophical themes I think that one
that of course the big elephant in the
room is cyberspace right coins the idea
he describes what it's like without
having any experience whatsoever of what
what was going on with computers pretty
remarkable he talks about it as a
collective hallucination that's one of
the things that the characters keep
saying over and over again so you got I
think he got that right about you know
what was going on with the neck because
if you think about how much were in a
world that is is real but is also like
infused with all these virtual elements
you know wait again think about what the
iPhone does for us right I mean here
you're like looking something up right
now right which what you're able to do I
you know I don't have to wear watch
because I know what time it is and I
have you know a thing that tells me
where I have to go on the map and email
and I think well do all sorts of other
things just able to track her mo oh yeah
and if you have a facebook you can check
in and say that you were safe yeah well
and then we were checking in the family
it's down there yeah to see what's going
on so it's you know it's it's pretty
amazing what the connectivity of the net
has provided and notice we don't like
Jackie and his characters do yeah it's a
lot more lightweight that's actually
texting my sister to see if she had
opinions but she oh cool answer see
great example of something like real and
virtual at the same time yeah yeah I
mean he pictures it's sort of like it's
this thing that can totally consumes us
like what we call virtual reality all
right
and I guess you know there's advanced as
in that probably I'm willing to bet that
most of the advances are going to be
caused through either the gaming
industry or the porn industry cuz
like like horn managed to drive a lot of
our industry things you know from from
cameras to website design to all those
sorts of things but also gaming you know
this is gonna be really big and then
it'll have all sorts of commercial
applications and I was like being in
time I mean now can we have the drone
operators right we're piloting these
drones and they're they're not
completely in a virtual reality
experience but that's pretty close
oh you know yeah another great example
is her commentary just the other day
about augmented reality
yeah where you don't really need a phone
but not a specialized equipment so much
yeah although it's interesting there's
there's there's a lot of speculation
that these you know are going to get
replaced ultimately by my smart glasses
in part because then we'd have to carry
these and it can be more just part of I
don't like that again myself I prefer
having something external it's relying
on a lot better here I muscle is like
thing yeah I'm gonna be steering that
well I think I think yeah they actually
you're probably gonna have to like learn
to do a lot of things with your eyes
like you know I mean how did how do you
click do you like bulging how to better
oh yeah yeah like you get an eyelash in
there and it's all over
yeah especially like you're doing the
finances you know something screwed up
would be really hard enter and watching
iris scan I guess that's probably iris
scan yeah but so you know what he's
talking about a cyberspace is something
quite different I mean we do we do see a
lot of the things that he's talking
about like
and breaking people's data going on and
countermeasures from that happening as
well but it's not something that we
visualize the way he was writing about
well right now we're dealing with
political implications that the authors
when these stories are being written to
even think about in many cases their
vision that kind of hacking well I mean
hacking of voting machines no well just
what was discussed the other day about
Facebook creating identities on Facebook
yeah true and Wow Twitter and Twitter
and having and creating political yeah
movements political protests and things
yeah
whole blocks of people so it looks like
there's there's really an organized or
or at least coherent group that I feel
this way right well it was like one
particularly Facebook page was there it
was no group it was a hacker okay who
set it up as if it was a brute and then
spurred people to do protests against
Muslims and Hispanics in he got
followers that this was a Russian bot
was a Russian hacker and they got all
these people to follow with a Facebook
page yeah and then they started
proposing well why don't you go protest
this why don't we all go protest this
and got people to actually show we
actually share a lot in real life yeah
that doesn't surprise me
yeah I'm getting interesting we had
Twitter like twice a week now on
average I'll get a comment and it will
be from this is what it's ultimately
like some porn site on Twitter and I'll
be like usually it's about like a video
of mine I'll be like great have you been
getting those to Twitter but tumblr has
a major problem and like this constant
battle of because of the administration
though yeah the users we kind of find
ways to self moderate and block yeah
better and better at imitating human
beings like they'll have usernames that
look like a name a human being would
actually choose us there and they can
they comment on all sorts of yeah but if
they're commenting on things that you
wouldn't think a porn back with Karen
yes that's also the weird thing so like
I don't have you Twitter or yeah but you
see it on Facebook and I see it on email
they're having better and better ways of
figuring out what will cause you to
click the click bait yeah yeah things
are getting more and more sophisticated
in the internet well I think because
they see your parents and on Facebook
all of a sudden I'm getting these sites
you know one thing one time and I'm
getting all these sites coming in that I
didn't like I've never I'm never coming
interestingly
but it used to be like if I like
research something you know it started
all the hats really so yeah now an Andy
research is something somehow they know
that word were connected and stuff that
she's researching very specific stuff
comes up as hands-on I'm like my Google
or my leg day you know really persistent
so that's a good transition to talking
about
yeah even Google+ which is not Oh Matt
sadistic yeah my husband was just saying
we were having dinner and he said Google
just sent me an email asking me to
review such and such a restaurant yeah
you know is it knew I was there it's
funny because I've made fun of Twitter
or his Twitter does targeted hands yep
and they're usually for things that I
would never in my life by and sometimes
I'm like this is so stupid and so I'll
you know I'll kind of troll them a bit
and say you know really funny that they
put this because I think this is a crap
and and here's why and stuff like that I
try to be a bit more witty about it but
it's refreshing that Twitter just hasn't
really gotten it yet
whereas like Google LinkedIn Facebook
they're on top of that yeah they know
you inside and out so a little good
transition to tack on another key theme
of this which is the role that a is
right because what we're talking about
there is it's any I but it's not a I in
the way that that we used to talk about
if we're for a long time
a I was it was all about can we get
things to pass the Turing test can we
fool people into thinking that an AI as
a human in other guys and one of the
very early programs for that was this um
I I started looking at it when I was a
kid back in the early eighties it was
called it was called Eliza and it was
written in basic was a Kendall long
program but the reason it was long is
because it had a number of different
like catch phrases built into it and
what it did is it took the input of what
you were saying it was supposed to mimic
a psychiatrist would be talking to you
so like you would write I'm feeling
depressed today I mean I would you know
that would be a string and I would say
I'm concerned that you're feeling
depressed today or what do you mean by
I'm feeling depressed it would get you
to start talking with it and and it only
had a certain amount of you know things
that I could say and so I'm actually you
would figure out it would be would fail
the Turing test you could figure out
there was a what we nowadays call a bot
right
yeah bots are very primitive forms of AI
but the thing that you're talking about
with these algorithms very very
sophisticated right and I mean Netflix
is like that too Netflix is one of the
first programs to really try to do that
make a selling point the 80 eyes of this
are incredibly sophisticated a lot of
them are are doing jobs for companies
like guarding their dad so they develop
you know mice that that's protecting it
and it's supposed to be more dense if
it's an AI but the a is the you know the
entire theme of Neuromancer is about
these two a eyes one of which is trying
to what Wintermute is trying to
manipulate things eventually break free
of its its confines and merge with the
other one who is Neuromancer who doesn't
really want emergent anybody because
Neuromancer has a personality winter me
or just adopts personalities but they're
manipulating all these things behind the
scene and then you know in the other
novels these Haitian you know voodoo
spirits or gods or you want to put them
a really gay ties within that Ghost
within the matrix and there's some hint
that maybe they're the result of
Wintermute and Neuromancer is fusing
together and escaping the confines you
know and it's interesting because if you
think about other AI scenarios what is
it that this is a it's a big topic right
now what are we really afraid of
happening there are these Turing police
in right and the Turing police are there
specifically to make sure that no AI is
able to augment itself because once you
let a AI system make itself better
there's no stopping it
and what are our fears well you know
in the Terminator we have what was it
Skynet this guy didn't become self-aware
realizes that human beings might shut it
down start shutting down human beings
the AI is that we have they could start
thinking they're bored inefficiencies in
the system nothing like that happens
with these AIS well the end of verse we
talked about the ender series fight oh
yeah what was the name of there was a
Jane Jane Pizza yeah yeah I think it's
Jane Jane does any I who become
self-aware
yeah and I'll mince herself across all
the answer that across the whole ansible
that yeah and then you get the debate
about do we have now an entity yeah and
is it is it can be it can they want to
it is it is it should we consider it to
be human
there was a to alien from us is it is it
has enough of personality enough of a
self-awareness that we can't shut it
down oh my guess of ethical constraints
these could hardly be murdered
interestingly in this the Turing police
they're ready to shut down any AI
because it seems like they they is our
self-aware right but as soon as so as
soon as they're gonna like change
themselves in any way you got to
immediately crack down on that because
there's no way of telling what they'll
do and it turns out Wintermute is is
interested primarily in just getting out
of its confines and doing something
different the other a is you know they
that are mentioned do like guidance of
people and they don't really do anything
they have other than no they do cause
some accidents
like that to advance the characters that
they're they're interested in but yeah
they there is that issue of well how do
you understand them how do we relate to
them now Gibson seems to think that
computers are less about the computer
entity itself and more about how we
humans relate ourselves to them how we
understand ourselves for them and one
interesting way of thinking about AI
that really fits in with like the
algorithms and stuff like that
is that Turing tests were never really
the way to go about things it's not
about creating something that imitates
the human and can pass as a human and
can thereby you know it's a certain
point become self-aware that's all cool
but what's really important in thinking
about AI is what AI does and how I
relate to you or you relate to her it's
an interface more than an entity by
itself and if you think about it that
way then we don't have to have AI being
something like an imitation of the human
yeah like we talked about you know we
didn't we didn't email right well if we
had a great a I assistant to do all that
that stuff and the emails would have
gone out on time simple things like that
but even that can even that we're out to
the point yet where that saw that
successful because I just hadn't
happened with Amazon I just I just
ordered under their new system yeah for
the drop boxes okay I put my first order
in under Amazon drop box yeah and it was
delivered today this morning to the drop
box and the way the system is supposed
to work and it's not controlled by
humans in the program whether you're
doing well you went he was following
this but they're supposed to send out an
email or text to tell him to tell you
it's there and here's your
yeah to access it didn't happen so you
just kind of sitting there it's sitting
there I happen to be tracking it because
the first time I've ever done this yeah
yeah so I was tracking delivery and
realized it had been delivered this
morning yeah I had not received a
message and I managed to get hold of
Amazon and they couldn't explain why
because the computer is it should have
no human intervention yeah Computers
just supposed to do it well this is a
great example of something something
Gibson and I think a lot of other
authors like Philip Yordan
are great at bringing out is exactly
that sort of thing where in theory
things are this way and in practice
things are constantly getting gummed up
and people have to intervene and it's
always like patchwork stuff and nobody
quite knows what's going now this of
course people are sort of exploiting
that right there you know using like
gaps to break into things and steal
information but in our own life it's a
bit more comic than one thing you're
thinking you were talking about hey uh
yeah
AI that can although not like making
humans but can behave in that in that
way
Wow and I'm thinking of all the sites
that I go to that one of the security
questions is I'm not a robot you know
that's true and if it's a sophisticated
AI would you click that so if aliens are
supposed to pass as heroes most humans
when it comes to most activities are
pretty dumb right so you could you could
like imagine like if I had to somehow
handle what Amazon shipping is doing are
you sure it's all good dude I'm sure I
didn't things in the wrong spots and be
reporting things you know your package
is there it's not good stuff yeah you
know we want and then sometimes we want
the a to be very very human but we
wanted to be like certain humans right
not the ones that are pains in the rear
not the ones who screw things up not the
ones who need a day off
these sorts of things and so we want
something that's kind of contradictory
probably you know and if the AI is
you're smart aware of us
I don't think you're thinking about AI
has a monster robot series oh well we
talk about it because there's nothing
like that in these that's insurance I
think it's yeah further along in the
books you have a robot who has no limits
yeah it has developed himself to the
point where he can he can be human
pretty much well that's where the robot
series and the later part of the
Foundation series connect up yeah come
together yeah
let me bring us to a different theme
which is that of power and like the
people who I mentioned projects right
you know things are giving meaning to
people's lives and one of the projects
in this or hey let's rob some money
that's let's get over in some way you
know let's jack in and you know break
through the ice and get the
formation from here and sell it to this
person but there are some big
organizations and there are still some
nation-states you know China has
mentioned Russia the United States
Brazil you know these things are still
doing things they don't control that
much the corporations even have a lot of
power there is also the mobs you know
the British bob is mentioned the Yakuza
is part of things and then there's
certain entities they seem to be they
have kind of niches cut out for them
one would be sense that right ones who
do all the this sim stem stuff and they
play a big role in this but then we've
got these other two things the test here
Ashville family and this guy burek and
there's even some theorization about
this in count zero there's an academic
who's writing a dissertation a great way
of working exams very smart move there
Gibson's part and they talk about how
these the what's what's going on with
with people who have so much power can
they keep it together can they focus on
on tasks where does that power just turn
into like an endless cycle of playing
around which is seem to be what happens
with the texture - poor family you know
it's described their their their space
places is described as just kind of
hodgepodge of all sorts of things put
together a very expensive things but
doesn't really make sense they start
cloning their kids and then thawing them
out and you know sometimes they do bad
stuff to them sometimes the kids get to
do whatever they want the the AIS are
created the ones that are important in
Neuromancer are created by the with
tesserae a school family as well
and they have some things built in this
Viereck guy is incredibly wealthy but
he's actually living his bodies is just
totally decrepit and he's a in a bunch
of would you call it like he's in a
bunch of tubes and and Bad's and he's
being kept alive but it's it's you know
the life that he lives is primarily
through the net and it's facilitated by
all the money that he has and clearly he
wants immortality and it seems like the
testicles also want immortality we just
go nuts it's unclear whether that's what
these end boxes are about they train up
all these these corporate things and
Gibson uses metaphors for them like
insects like bees or wasps they just
keep reproducing over and over again
trading up new generations doesn't seem
like a very meaningful life you know so
the question is where do you get meaning
it doesn't have to be in struggle I
think it's kind of good open question
particularly as we're like approaching a
time where we might have to if we want
if you don't want society to completely
collapse we might have to like give
everybody a universal basic income
what's going to keep people from like
what's going to keep the the regular
people from going nuts and then what's
going to keep the rich and the powerful
from equally going nuts when there's no
new things to do we just yeah and they
do the rich to prey on the poor that
that can give them some meaning for a
while but that doesn't last very long
cruelty gets pretty boring it seems for
a lot of people
it's very unclear or headed and I think
his his novels the characters that we
have they have always got some sort of
drives right because they have a mission
where they're in downtime
a lot of them have no idea what the hell
they do how they get in trouble and you
know do dumb stuff well we see that
today with military yeah and with you
talking to Lisa earlier with people who
are in first responder type positions
when they're responding you know they're
in the field they have a purpose yeah
they know exactly what they're doing you
take them out of that and they have
difficulty coping yeah
many of them not all but many have real
difficulty coping with the world that's
different from when they're in the field
yeah because when they're in the field
the purpose is very clear it's very
simple it's very clear that happens even
like it with managers I had a guy whose
client who was great when things were in
crisis mode and then of the things got
routine and he started feeling at the
core we found some without Drive and he
would start to
let things slide and then of course the
crisis well that's what I suggested
enough to be Freud to figure but he was
really he was genuinely troubled by and
I suggested making I made me needed to
learn how to manage I know routine life
I guess a crisis lets you rise to it
right and so there's there's a lot
there's a lot to be thought about with
that I mean case he has all these like
poison sacs and has had that are gonna
door off and if he doesn't come
if he hasn't get things right Molly what
is her motivation I think I think that
sounds right Armitage is just a complete
you know screwed up mass he's not even a
real person anyway there's other
characters who are just kind of you know
screwed up
motivations is like rivera and then we
can say the same thing for each of these
other characters as well a lot of
writers have looked at if he had passed
a certain point how didn't keep purpose
in life yeah and I wasn't anybody spoke
with the answer yet
not entirely
that's true yeah yeah that's that's a
big issue for the what was the mainland
culture the culture yeah their own
projects yeah but you notice the ones
that were more interesting were the ones
who became part of my special yeah yeah
because at least then you get to like
engage the outside yeah so that's
actually a good transition to this whole
notion of like losing your overarching
narrative or a purpose one of the things
that give some talks about the
postmodern right and we talked today
about a post-modernism
that's an idea strangely enough that's
been around long enough that it's really
not postmodern anymore it's older than
you know but us and it's it's kind of
yeah in many ways it's kind of funny
that that nowadays people on the right
are like you know attacking Foucault and
Gary died and you know Deleuze as if
anybody on the Left actually reads them
you know and does something from them
they're like post-modernism is banned
and nobody really knows what
post-modernism means there's a whole
bunch of different theories out there
ultimately there's something like well
there's no oh there's no single
meta-narrative that makes sense of
everything that you can be on that
nobody quite knows what it means now I
don't think that Gibson is a post
modernist at all I think that he's he's
quite happy to be new writing
essentially modernist literature right
neo-noir cast in a cyberpunk situation
but it is writing about a postmodern
condition in which everything is kind of
jumbled up together and one of the cool
things that did people did say is about
the postmodern is that the postmodern is
sort of the modern continued and
continued to continue if you think about
this notion of modern right people have
been using that word for 200 years now
talking about how the previous
generation was antiquated and we got to
get rid of their their their crazy stuff
and them do the modern thing right and
look back on all these you know things
that countered is modern and we're like
oh that's that's so quaint you know now
hipsters use that and you know are you
actually going to you know use that
rotary phone they go to rotary phones
were incredibly modern for a while and
then we have you know cordless phones
and that was very modern and now you
know I mean we've got this this brick
circuits and stuff like that who'd
possibly have one of those those crazy
cordless phones that's like this big and
I mean that some people still have them
but you know they're they're kind of
curiosities right and so the postmodern
part of that is that things just keep
you know going out and on and change it
and and
not always improving necessarily but
certainly developing by gas stations are
a great example you know okay the
problem to turn postmodern it suggests
that we're done that's true yeah
modernist it's finish you know past it
yeah it's like these are the term
post-race post-racial the ox' racial
yeah we solved all of that saudeleurs
and therefore probably the term
postmodern suggests we've solved all our
problems
yeah we're at the pinnacle or were just
rejected are we just rejecting the
modern completely yeah and I mean those
were Gibson talking about like capital
our future and the lowercase future I
think that's a really smart way to go
about looking at the post modernists are
like saying and we are in the future you
know and it's nothing like what we
thought it was going to be I mean we're
still pumping gas into internal
combustion engines there are nine
hundred cars you know they're not flying
around they don't fold up like the
Jetson thing into your suitcase and and
we can't continue that forever we're
gonna run on fossil fuels
pretty soon and we'll find some some
other you know crazy thing to continue
out of this and there's probably still
gonna be gas stations but who knows what
they'll look like they probably won't
take credit cards because we'll have
chips or something like that right but
it'll still be the same kind of stuff
going on and I guess the point is you're
never so postmodern that you leave
behind the everything and enter into a
totally new domain stop being you so
that's another thing that I was talking
when you when you get past your daily
routines the how we do business how and
I had some party you might color our
existential condition right yeah I know
things like having a job I'm gonna worry
about rent and I have I have discussions
with people who are somewhat older than
me periodically about cell phones and
say oh yeah and the the concept of well
it's you it's driving people part of
this ruining connection and yet we sit
here and you text your sister to find
out yeah and I say I'm actually in touch
with more people than I was and I just
had a phone yeah
our invoice if it was reduced to what I
used to communicate with with itself
with with just a phone phone my circle
of who I'm in touch with in my family
and thus and not bow friends but actual
human connections has grown it's
actually bigger so that's played an
incredibly huge role in that I think
it's more personal rather than right
yeah instead of letters or occasional
Christmas cards
[Music]